you have a knack for getting in trouble
you have a knack for saving my life for
me it was a great love story with a real
human being a sentient somebody that I
could really identify with somebody who
had to do homework come on who the girls
weren't crazy about somebody was bullied
and yes he had to rise up and become a
hero to protect the city and it seemed
like they had never heard that version
before I had great graphic images of how
spider-man lamb what his pose looks like
how he swings from a web the jobless
bring that vision to the big screen how
would we do that how would we get active
moving away that only a comic book
artist could detect that was really the
challenge and it was just to make it as
real as we could when Toby's hanging
upside down in the pouring rain and
she's all wet this is the moment when
Peter to both achieve his dream of
helping a woman he loved it's also
finally getting to kiss the woman he
loved the vulnerability that he exposes
to her I think that's why her pulling
down the math makes them on a special
because his character longs to be loved
by her and to remove the masking
exposing herself to becoming vulnerable
to someone who loves you there was a
considerable amount of the set-up time
we're actually outside on the back lot
with big rain machines but to be able to
see rain and movies actually a lot
bigger drops than real-life rain - and
you're getting rained on in the movies
it's a lot of water you take out your
tank and they're being doused in cold
water and it can become really chilling
but we would have to get out there get
in position get the rain going and then
we would have to lift Toby up on the
wire upside down in the position you saw
him in the movie and that would take a
couple minutes so it's a few minutes of
misery each time we do the take and
while he was doing the scene I remember
the water was falling down into his
upside-down not so so he was kind of
drowning but it was the kissing scene so
he had to pretend that it was a pleasant
sweet moment for him and exactly was
Demi drowning then the only basic reason
to his mouth and then I had a mistress
and they seem to do very well with it
it was more about trickery of the mask
itself we could
really get that look on the mask and
have it be pliable so it really wouldn't
pull up and down and we had to pretend
as though it were but Gerson's doing a
little bit of sleight of hand to help
sell the idea that she actually pulled
the mask down it was a lot of technical
aspects but fortunately Kirsten and Toby
are still convincing that they made that
all invisible I felt the pressure that
the genre was in trouble Hollywood was
soured on the superhero film around 1999
I honestly in my heart think that this
movie and how Sam did it absolutely set
the tone of how the comic with me we
should be made I love families work and
I was trying to be true to it and if
people recognized from the spider-man
movies that his stories were really
effective then I'm proud